[Music]
[Applause]
their first step what are you so many
adventures we're going to Tuolumne
trailhead this is the trail we're going
to be walking into this tree you can
actually walk through you used to be
able to drive through it but it's in
closed 35 years cousin even here yeah I
wasn't either
[Music]
we'll be four little fire damage trees
last year there's one of the biggest
fires ever in California don't touch the
cold
we're coming up on the first fig tree
that we're going to see on our walk and
this isn't even the biggest tree this is
considered a medium-sized tree what kind
of tree was on again
I'm score at the giant sequoia
so this is the tree in reference to the
size of my body
Oh
Justices regimens depart in zelda where
the girl was telling me to stay off the
plan that's what I feel like right now
actual tree of the tunnel
[Music]
right now my camera is sitting on a tree
that fell over 1984 it is not decomposed
as much as my body has oh my goodness
this is crazy
oh my goodness I'm inside of a tree this
is crazy
we're inside of the dead tree right now
guys what do you think yeah you can go
down about 50 ah stone is a big hole
[Music]
developing news guys there's a fair
traffic jam there's a mama and her
little baby Cubs and we're going to get
to see them gosh I wish I have that one
one of my favorite things are traveling
is checking out gas station so we're
stopping here in a little gas station
let's see what they've got
you've got some wild bagel oh this is
like a little tiny snorted it's
incredible huh baby honey this is cool
The Moth entik pounds game Oh simple
corn in bulk totally well I can barely
find no r'mante at home and they have
had every single flavor at every place
that I've won crispy buttery gras we're
outside to the State Park because you're
not allowed to fly drones in shape our
Morgan takes this little bad boy up and
get some super cool shot
[Music]
the
people say that people say I should say
that way people
Cooper
[Music]
okay I'm gonna try the palm landing ah
it's nuts it's absolutely crazy so this
is the Merced River Valley Canyon and
we're not quite yet Yosemite Canyon as
you guys can see right here you'll see a
little beef and that is where are you
somebody can you start for now a cascade
Falls is so beautiful the waterfall runs
underneath of this highway and on to the
other side
[Music]
now making a quick little pit stop here
to bridle the ill falls so on behind us
is called ribbon Falls that normally it
only run for about six weeks out of the
years but since they had a pretty
intense winter it's been running for a
little bit longer
[Music]
I'm getting crazy
ever since the Mac operating system was
called Yosemite and then the next
version was El Capitan that's the only
thing that I wanted to do I wanted to go
and visit Yosemite and then visit El
Capitan
so we're here we made it my goal has
been complete that our out copies on ok
well yeah well blow the game right bye
[Applause]
oh yeah
so this is one of the be tallest
waterfalls in the United States yes
[Applause]
the base is all cast on and behind us is
Cathedral and there are people climbing
the thing right now the fastest anyone
has ever climbed it freestyle is about 2
hours 24 minutes to 20 or our thing you
also might check out record right now so
fast but usually it will take a couple
of days to actually climb up the entire
mountain the people sleep on the edge in
little beds they put themselves to the
side of the mountain that's insane
that's pretty crazy I've got two drones
in my backpack right now how many - I
got two Thrones - please it's just so
crazy that like this look there we are
there we are so long as there's no
interruption Wi-Fi transmissions you can
go a little bit over a mile there's our
shot take it around like this get in my
shot
a real thing out I'm asked a spark we
made it back from a long adventure and
you guys know basically like I asked
Jenna look my favorite food this
probably wanted to think she would say
meatballs
[Music]
the temperature is extremely confusing
because it is so warm yet we're trudging
in snow we're heading up the Sentinel
dome and then we're heading to a place
called a glacier which I feel like I'm
on a glacier right now you know I have
the same question so this is where we
are standing yesterday where I took this
picture and here we are above the
waterfall elk every times over here to
my left
yes oh oh yeah just follow it took a
tumble
let it feel made to the top of that
Knoll dome eyeless fellow few times it's
okay we're here now definitely have not
worn the best Footwear to climbing up a
really know what's that it's Markus keen
again with the coordinate okay you
better be there when I shake watch me
work if I can stuff if I should fall
just go ahead we're gonna head back down
now oh boy this is gonna be great
because it's all snowy Oh
Oh Oh God
my buddies Joe going down so you
survived that downward spiral now we're
heading off to glacier once we get back
to the car and get snack
[Music]
finally meet at the glacier point
they're talking about it all day so
every time we got to a place I thought
the rear Glacier Point but no we're here
now let's go on the map yep that's us on
our honor of laggin
[Music]
I put a cool movie shot I don't you guys
are bad in the physics videos yeah so
this is the most famous spot like in the
valley there's a ton of you it's
incredibly beautiful I mean we've been
all of them down these mountains and
it's kind of crazy standing here and
looking at all the places where we've
been this is a
oh wow money goes when there's a ton of
snuff honey for a few weeks or a year
that's the end of our Yosemite trip
we're backing up now it's super early
and we're going to be heading back to LA
so hope you guys enjoyed our video make
sure you go check out Jenna's video you
basically have the same video but it's
basically Jenna's version I mean it's
kind of hard to make it different when
we did the same exact stuff so Hugh are
in line
[Music]
[Applause]